presidential candidate better O'Rourke
made his name as the national Democrat
in Texas last year when he nearly
unseated Republican senator Ted Cruz
lost by three percentage points the two
opponents appeared on 60 minutes just
days before that election at the time or
Roarke insisted he would not run for
president in 2020 no matter what he said
we asked him about changing his mind and
how he's already been mocked by the
president president Trump has already
weighed in on your candidacy he said
this about you he's got a lot of hand
movement is he crazy or is that just the
way he acts you do have a lot of
handlers I'm not saying that's good or
bad I'm pretty I'm pretty animated I
call that passion I I remember when we
were campaigning in Texas someone pulled
me aside he said hey I just want to give
you some free advice you move around too
much when you talk I am Who I am
and I really do think that we all want
to get past the pettiness the personal
attacks we've got some real big
challenges in front of us and some
extraordinary opportunities let's make
the most of them and let's do that
together let's not put anybody down
instead let's lift each other up I've
heard better work described as a star
and Barrow Rourke
described as a loser in the same
sentence Starr because look what he did
in Texas with that race who came within
three percentage points in a deep red
state loser because at the end of the
day he lost the race what do you say to
that he couldn't win in his own state
how can he win the country yeah I lost
that race but in the process of running
that campaign we were able to help
change the the face of democracy in
Texas so many young people who
understand that their voice and their
vote will make a difference in their
future so many candidates who were
running along with us who won their
elections and might not otherwise have
been able to do so in some way we were
part of some much larger victory for our
state and for our country and now Texas
counts so where's the loser part of that
sentence and I tell you at the end of
the day squarely that is is on me and
it's it's a recognition that you can
always do
a better job there's always the ability
to learn from your mistakes but in so
doing I don't want to lose sight of the
fact that we got to be part of a
tremendous movement and community whose
power still persists long after that
election in this particular with the
Democratic candidates there are more
women and more people of color than ever
before some could say it's the way the
party is leaning that maybe the voters
are signaling that's the candidate we
want yeah do you feel at a disadvantage
as a white man as a privileged white man
they say about you I don't feel at a
disadvantage and at the same time I feel
extraordinarily grateful that the
Democratic Party has produced so many
extraordinary candidates each of whom
brings a different set of skills and
life experiences and background this is
a great moment for America it's a great
moment for the Democratic Party and I
count myself so lucky to be a part of it
I really want to see Beto why you feel
so strongly that you are the one when
you really sat down in your heart of
hearts and said you know I want this job
yeah I'll tell you this is very much a
personal decision one that I made with
my family with my wife Amy and when we
think about what's going on in this
country and when we think about our kids
and their future we really do then look
back at ourselves and our responsibility
to do everything we can but I'm curious
about your family decision because after
the 60 Minutes interview I know
everybody has a right to change your
mind you were so adamant about I'm not
going to do it yeah the family would not
survive yeah Henry your youngest said I
would cry every day if you run for the
presidency so what changed for you and
the family after the campaign that we
ran for Texas and after election night
the best decision was made by my wife
Amy where she said there are lots of
people who are talking about us doing
lots of different things let's instead
of trying to figure that out right now
just spend some time as a family
that's really what we did I was able we
were able to see just how resilient and
strong our kids were and as Amy and I
came closer to making this decision we
didn't have a sit-down conversation with
our kids they just voluntarily started
offering advice hey Dad if you
this is how I think you should do it or
hey Dad you've got a run because of this
or that issue these were the
conversations on the ride home from
school or unsolicited and I honestly did
not expect that but I think they're just
as sensitive to what's going on in the
world right now they understand that
they will inherit the consequences of
the choices that you and I make at this
moment and they're counting on us to
make the right ones so he's got three
kids Ulysses who's 12 Molly who's 10
Henry who's 8 so there's still little
guys and they all know the toll it's
going to take but he of course he has a
family support 150 percent but it was
interesting everywhere he goes people
how do you say your name is it bado is
it Beto and somebody's campaign says
it's Beto like you can bet on him that's
a good way to remember it those of you
who are trying to figure out how do you
say this guy's name but he's a
fascinating person and a lot of people
are getting to know him for the first
time but it's now 599 days till election
so you got a lot of time I'm sitting
here asking you did you ask him this did
yes are you gonna put more of it sort of
out online so that yes he says I called
social okay social it's going up right
now okay good